seule revendication à l'époque un tract
retrouvé le 17 novembre au soir au métro
raspail
quelques heures auparavant georges besse
avait été abattu devant son domicile
action directe signé cet attentat
commando pierre overney mais les
enquêteurs noter qu'à aucun moment le
nom du pdg de renault n'était cité de
plus le tract était une photocopie et
les experts ne pouvait établir avec
certitude l'origine de la machine à
écrire
aujourd'hui c'est dans ce texte de 26
pages qu action directe explicite son
attentat le commando pierre overney dit
le groupe clandestin à frapper au coeur
même de la contradiction la plus forte
au sein du consensus général de
pacification et d'exploitation trop
habituel du groupe décortiqué dès à
présent par les services de police
trois jours après l'attentât les photos
de nathalie ménigon et de joëlle aubron
étaient envoyés dans tous les
commissariats de france leur portrait
placardés dans paris l'anc est pourtant
n'a guère progressé depuis novembre deux
femmes ont été vues sur les lieux du
crime
mais rien ne permet encore aujourd'hui
d'affirmer qu'il s'agit d' obrou et de
ménigon